dude but you also like have legendary
roles like highlander which i know you
talk about ad nauseam and like starship
troopers and like i mean these movies
when you do them
i mean obviously when you're working
with sean connery and highlander you're
like sean connery's and it's gonna be a
big movie right
you thought that yeah that movie is a
complete accident yeah
i don't know if you i don't know if you
know anything about that movie i know
but
the guy the guy that wrote it greg wyden
he was a he was a college kid he was i
think he was an undergrad
you know usc or ucla or wherever the
hell he was and that was his
he wrote this script as his final for
some
cinema script writing class that he did
and
uh and then these uh these
these buzzards these scavengers uh
that were the producers as
these two guys whose i won't mention
their names they
they sort of like take over they sort of
pick over these things and they go in
and they snag a script that's
you know maybe won an award or or you
know
got an a or whatever it is and they and
they pay the guy
you know five hundred dollars just five
hundred dollars for your script area
and then they then they go and they
pitch it
to the wherever they had the deal and
uh and i think they said they would pay
you know they paid him a couple thousand
bucks and a portion of the
of the budget if if uh you know a
percentage of the budget
if it gets if it gets made if it gets
picked up and made and that's because
yeah and they're low budget guys so they
you know they're thinking they're going
to pay them
maybe another 10 grand or something so
then uh
they as these producers do they just go
out to big stars anyway
you know they expecting to get turned
down and so they went to
they went to sean connery and said hey
we want you to play the highlander i
don't even think they even
read the script they just said you know
highlander
that's a scottish man so let's go to the
big scottish
scott movie star so they sent it to
him and he said no he said no i'm not
interested in doing that but i would be
interested in playing
ramirez and so suddenly they had
interest from
sean connery and the budget goes up and
then they said well if we can get him to
play ramirez let's
let's go get you know let's get somebody
to who we're going to get to play the
highlander and then
you know they start casting around
somebody says well you know you should
send it out to this uh
this young french actor who just won the
cesar for his role in subway and you
know he's
he's a he's a big european star so
they sent it out to kristoff and he said
oh sean connery's in it i'll do it
so it's so then they had the big
european star the biggest european star
at the time
at the time uh the budget goes up yeah
the budget goes up again
and so then they go out to uh arnold
schwarzenegger because he had just done
a terminator and they said
we're going to get arnold schwarzenegger
and the president couldn't go up again
arnold schwarzenegger said nah i
i i don't want to play a bad guy again i
don't want to play that guy
i want to play so the budget goes
oh down what are we going to do what are
we going to do and
the director they got
they got a director out of australia who
had
basically made his bones doing music
videos named russell mulcahy
although he had directed a really
terrific
horror movie called razorback which is
kind of like jaws in the outback
in australia and they got him
for probably not much money uh but he's
but really talented guy
and uh and so russell was like
hanging out with his music video friends
and he talks to
he was talking to sting and they're like
yeah you know russell said
we went out to i don't know who we're
gonna get we went out to schwarzenegger
he turned us down and things said well i
just worked with this big
uh this big american bloke
named clancy brown on this movie called
the bride you know he's
he seems like a pretty good actor he's
like a pretty good guy i want you to
check out him so i met with the
he calls up the producer said check out
this other guy this clancy bryant guy
and i met with those guys
i'm like i i think it's a great
story yeah i would love to play it but
you know how much you're gonna pay me
and they don't pay me they don't want to
pay me anything
and i don't have a quote or anything but
rich of anything so they pay me nothing
and they're thrilled because they pay me
nothing they get their
they get their movie made and we go and
we make the movie and greg
is you know he's this kid out of college
who wrote this thing and suddenly he's a
millionaire because he gets a
percentage of of a real budget and
and his career is launched right after
this is moving
so this random act of yeah we'll give
you a couple of thousand dollars second
choice
if the budget goes up you'll get a
percentage it's one in a million it's
like winning the lottery you're most
likely it's never going to get made
you're going to make zero money and the
guy becomes a millionaire takes his
career off
right there's a bunch of people that won
the lottery they paid sean a ton of
dough
and you know i think it made kristoff a
big star
and uh and he got a lot of money i got
nothing
i got i got no money oh residuals you
got residuals
yeah no no didn't get residuals because
it was under a basket contract
oh my god and you're like a major
character
i mean come on oh the son of a bees